what's up my name is IDO Mathieu Swansea
my name is Evan been on my name is Jill
Mariano and I'm a male model
[Music]
so I love style and fashion I just don't
like paying a lot for it these guys are
in style in fashion they get paid for it
it's their job they're experts but I
want to know can they really tell the
difference between cheap and expensive
clothing let's find out the spot you
versus expensive that's a no-brainer I
could spot that from like a mile away I
try on clothes for a living I wear
expensive clothes every day my boxers
probably cost more than your outfit no I
like to wear nicer things that fit
really well I made out a really great
material and I think I can tell the
difference between the cheap stuff and
the more expensive stuff so I'm pretty
confident
[Music]
first test you got these cars right here
Oh
one to increase um cheapest to most
expensive you guys together collectively
need to figure out which ones which I
want to see if you guys are right if you
actually know what you're talking about
let's bring of the guys on in fellas
okay so here we go the rules are no
touching but see what you guys got we're
off the bat I'm thinking that was the
most expensive that leather that leather
just looks like genuine leather the
details there zippers and all that stuff
so what y'all think about these I think
the brown is trying to throw us on like
oh this is an expensive jacket I think
it's that she was Jeff I think so too
I think so come on my bad bro so you
guys made your choice
this is this is your final answer yep
okay okay guys can you reveal your
actual numbers please
[Applause]
so fast so what made you think that this
one was the most expense it's so
detailed
let them better looks good to me yeah
and it's really gleaming in that light
you guys didn't do that well that was a
fluke okay make your decisions do your
choice on the hop out okay see if you
see these sleeves over here the
stitching stuff doesn't look good on the
end look see how it's one of the forums
like yeah yeah kind of like freedom I'm
leaning towards this being the most
expensive right here because if you look
at this look at study on the sleeve
right here look how clean that it is oh
yeah that is really real quick ladies
yeah this one Falls a little bit boxy
other than that one that one that was
like falling real nice like it's on a
hanger right I was leaning this being
the cheapest and that'd be in the medium
that's what I'm thinking that's you do
that is do that so just to clarify we
got most expensive okay with that right
we got number two right here
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is this is what you guys chosen
that's it yeah yeah yeah okay
can everybody please reveal what your
actual prices are Oh what what something
about that ah I know you're all right
buddy
something was messy yeah he's mental the
middle that quality looks nice though
okay you guys are smarter you didn't get
anyone was stitching on it I'm thinking
middles expensive yeah it was expensive
I think these are the least expensive
right here is that free I don't know
what's going on here but where
hey boy yeah we gotta go yeah I like
this one
me too I'm feeling good hi so final
answers this is it that's nice your Papa
got it okay you guys reveal your real
prices please hook them up like a nice
lesson here today I mean I feel like
personally it doesn't take a lot of
money to look good no I don't think so
yeah thank you so so much for
participating today you guys were
awesome you know good sports about the
whole thing
not really good at like you know
predicting prices and your job like so
obviously you guys only get paid for
being pretty that's about that's go
that's go